tilly ici purement fonctionnel par
l'ingéniosité de ses agencements par ces
extrême raffinement technique par c'est
formidable de dimension mirabel en effet
à l'once l'an 2000 quelle histoire
c'était le 4 octobre 1975
pierre elliott trudeau qui annonçaient
la naissance d'un géant d'un monstre du
plus grand aéroport au canada qu'elle et
desservir bien sûr le canada le monde
air canada était bien sûr derrière
allait faire atterrir ses avions etc
on connaît la suite on a parlé au début
toronto s'est accaparé le gros du marché
on a décidé de tout concentré au milieu
des années 90 à dorval
ironiquement aéroports que l'on nomme
l'aéroport pierre elliott trudeau je
vous lis un petit message que j'ai reçu
tout à l'heure ça vaut la peine
en 1969 j'avais 8 ans expropriés j'ai
tellement pleuré aujourd'hui cette
tristesse me revient et un immense
dégoût
cc il faut se replacer dans le contexte
le nombre d'agriculteurs de maisons
qu'on a déplacé qu'on a brûlé je vous
présente un reportage dans sébastien
cloutier nous présente l'histoire
rapidement et ensuite on a le grand
patron d'adp et m avec nous est un
spécialiste jacques roy que vous
expliquer l'autopsié d'un gage c'était
la belle époque celle de l'expo à la fin
des années 60
montréal a le vent dans les voiles on
estime que l'aéroport de dorval sera
bientôt trop petit il faut un autre
aéroport en 69 à la surprise générale
ottawa annonce que le site choisi est
sain scolastique devenu mirabel 60 km au
nord de la ville un plan d'expropriation
dix fois plus gros que tous les plus
grands aéroports du monde est annoncé
pour la population locale
c'est le choc
3126 famille douze mille personnes sont
expropriés parmi elle rita lafond qui
s'est longtemps battu pour leurs droits
on vous souhaite de ne jamais vous fait
déposséder de façon aussi que lui et
elle casse est que l'acier on avait le
teint un peu plus loin on avait les
radios
il a beau lot avec nous elle a accepté
de revenir voir son ancien chez soi de
nous raconter l'impuissance et la
douleur de l'époque
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui lawson de mal à
petit saut de son mari un agriculteur
est mort il ya deux ans elle se rappelle
sa colère le jour où ils ont brûlé leurs
maisons dans le chemin
il y est venu chez moi y ont pillé prix
des années 20 avant d'accepter qu'on lui
avait tout investissement aurait depuis
quitté petits pas tellement loin de là
en 1970 la construction de l'aéroport
commence cinq ans et 500 millions de
dollars plus tard
mirabel est inaugurée en grande pompe ce
que nous voyons sera d'ici 50 ans
multiplié par six l'aéroport occupent
seulement 5 % du territoire expropriés
mais on voit grand
c'est le projet du siècle pour pierre
elliott trudeau on imagine jour mirabel
avec six pistes et 40 millions de
passagers par année
mais l'aéroport ne dépassera jamais les
trois millions de passagers
d'abord la crise du pétrole fait mal et
le prix des billets d'avion monte en
flèche
la croissance économique se déplace
aussi vers toronto de 1975 à 1990 le
nombre de passagers à montréal croit de
31 pour cent à toronto 2 92%
les circonstances ont fait par la suite
que c'est devenu une erreur mais ce qui
fait peut-être le plus mal c'est que
mirabel est loin de montréal et les
correspondances avec dorval sont
compliqués la promesse de prolonger
l'autoroute 13 jusqu'à l'aéroport ne
sera jamais réalisé il n'y aura jamais
non plus de lien ferroviaire alors les
compagnies aériennes délaisse mirabel et
en 97 c'est le début de la fin les
aéroports de montréal devenu
gestionnaire
décès de transférer les vols
internationaux vers dorval le dernier
vol de passagers quittera mirabel le 31
octobre 2004 depuis dix ans l'aéroport
est seulement utilisé pour le transport
de marchandises et pour les besoins de
compagnie comme bombardier au moins le
combat de rita lafond aura servi en 1984
81 des 97 1000 acres où on avait
exproprié ont été revendus aux
agriculteurs elle et son mari n'ont pas
racheter leurs terres leur rêve était
mort et aujourd'hui pour elle un autre
rêve vient de mourir des fêtes de cette
année au galop quelque chose de vivant
composent il de la mort ont fait surgir
la vie mais non on continue à tort à
détruire et si je sais pas si tout si
radio canada ira bel james cherry vous
êtes président directeur général
d'aéroports de montréal
d'abord cette décision de démolir une
grande partie de l'aérogare escale est
irrévocable mais revient le vocable en
fait les décisions que nous avons pris
c'est très simple j'ai demandé j'ai reçu
l'autorité de notre conseil
d'administration de procéder à un appel
d'offres
en fait nous sommes pas experts dans le
domaine de la dépollution et nous avons
demandé la permission d'aller publics et
d'avoir une formation
suite à ça on va décider de procéder ou
non
ça nous donne je pense qu'il ya des gens
comme la mère de méribel qui prétendent
le projet intéressant nous ont un peu
pas vu le détail encore médias toujours
influent est une fenêtre courtes pendant
dix période quand on peut avoir une
opportunité d'évaluer des projets parce
que bernard landry d'ailleurs qui a pris
la tête d'un groupe rapidement là depuis
quelques jours on vous dira on pourrait
peut-être faire un salon aéronautique
comme le bourget ici est ce que ces
solutions là ont été envisagées est-ce
que vous avez pas assez vous toutes les
alternatives possibles avant d'arriver à
l'addition de démolir
effectivement avec nous nous avons parlé
de plusieurs solutions en fait parmi eux
aussi c'était un salon
tepbo geofarm euros mais il faut dire
qu'un salon comme ça se passe dans sur
un tarmac sur les pistes et pas dans un
bâtiment en fait si le projet est ce
dire est un projet on peut réaliser ça
sur le site des rebelles mais pas dans
ce bâtiment
je suis persuadé que l'abattement c'est
pas le type de bâtiment qui peuvent être
utilisés pour ce genre de faits mais
nous avons simplement des terrains et
s'il ira aux projets bien définis bien
financé appuyé par l'industrie locale
parce que je peux même plus ma machine
est un salon aéronautique qui a pas
supporté par bombardier pratt and
whitney hainaut mais s'il ya une douce
après de jouer avec eux en termine à
monsieur gerry qui qui est responsable
de ce fiasco
quel fiasco mais l'avenir de mirabel on
a bâti on a exproprié déjà il ya plus un
voyage à vous êtes prêt qu'une bâtisse
fantôme depuis 2002 195 qui selon vous
est responsable de ce fiasco
mais en toute honnêteté j'étais 14 ans à
nos portes mais je pense 5 à la décision
a été prise de construire mario plan là
je pensais c'était 20h01 donc à
l'origine vous dites it est une erreur
on n'avait pas les moyens
si on avait mis un lien rapide si on
avait mis un train sont avait sur s'est
arrangé pour relier mirabel à montréal
on n'aurait pas pu faire vivre l'art ou
pas fait effectivement mais c'est tout
les premiers secours pour les raisons de
continuer de méribel est effectivement
la croissance de trafic en terme de
l'évolution du trafic en termes de le
type d'appareil aussi toutes les
hypothèses qu'ils ont utilisés pour
construire rebelles sont jamais
réalisées se dit que tout la fondation
du projet était [ __ ] le souk chérie je
rappelle le président d'adp et aime donc
responsable et vous avez demandé
aujourd'hui qu'on lance le processus
d'offre pour démolir une grande partie
de l'aérogare merci d'avoir été avec
nous avec nous également jacques roy
professeur titulaire spécialiste en
gestion du transport ou hec montréal
étant un des grands spécialistes de tout
ça monsieur roy vous allez nous
expliquer qu'on comprenne dans un
langage très clair
comme disent les anglais what went wrong
est ce qui est arrivé dans ce dossier là
à ce point très complexe évidemment
quand on ne construit mirabel on voyait
grand hall vu dans votre reportage
les prévisions étaient très optimistes
et en fait on a probablement vu trop
grand mais une fois qu'on a construit
mirabel depuis qu'il est là on s'est
empressé de terminer l'aérogare parce
que veillée du jour et des pics en 76
donc aux saisies en votre transférer les
vols internationaux qu'on finira le
reste plus tard c'est à dire qu'on
transférons des vols intérieurs
transfrontaliers en 82 bon on constate
aujourd'hui évidemment que ça n'a pas eu
lieu on n'a pas complété le projet
pourquoi on n'a pas transféré à l'époque
les vols intérieurs parce que trop loin
le centre-ville
non c'est que la distance on établir sur
tout de suite c'est un plus que
l'aéroport soit loin parce qu'un héros
par ses nuisances par des riverains qui
habitent près des gens encore
aujourd'hui se plaignent du bruit
les nouveaux aéroports on est construit
le plus loin possible du centre-ville
mais on reconnaître ses aéroports avec
tous les moyens possibles des autoroutes
les trains les métros et a commandé deux
temps d'accès est raisonnable même si
aéroport est loin par mirabel avait
cette qualité d'être loin mais le défaut
d'être difficilement accessibles parce
qu'on n'a pas complété les
infrastructures ah si on avait transféré
le restant des vols pour qu'on puisse
avoir des correspondances raisonnable à
ce moment-là et de connecter on aura un
héros pas aujourd'hui qui serait
totalement fonction du jour
fonctionnelles alors que là on a pris
une décision et six aéroports de
montréal qui a décidé de ramener des
vols à dorval à l'époque et donc de vie
des mirabelles de ses passagers d'où
vous est très sévère avec
l'administration d'aéroports de montréal
le président vient de l'entente vous
dites qu'ils sont responsables du manque
de vision en grande partie vous blâmez -
air canada - les gouvernements
en fait mon un rôle à jouer air canada
l'époque était très heureuse
pour rapatrie les vols à dorval parce
qu'ils avaient leur fabuleuse base
d'entretiens qui est devenu avs et qui a
fermé aujourd'hui malheureusement à
l'époque c'est très important pour air
canada de fonctionner à dorval tout près
de cette base entretien par contre mais
j'avais étudiants 93 cette question et
j'avais rencontré tous les transporteurs
européens qui étaient mis la bulle
époque et tous sans exception ont dit on
peut vivre clé 2 0 par le mali fait
passer jean correspondance au hézo perdu
mais de grâce si vous en choisissez un
choisissez mirabel
sinon à dorval vous allez vous retrouver
conte et repas un clavier justement eu
ce déchirement là pendant quelques
années et qu'est-ce qui a fait pencher
la balance vers dorval parce qu'on s'est
dit il faut en choisir un seul mirabel
ou dorval pour nadine on devra les plus
proches
ouais effectivement donné deux constats
coûter très cher des centaines de
millions pour rapatrier à un ou à
l'autre et avec très peu de gay parce
que le mal était fait des passagers en
correspondance était déjà toronto
toronto est en train de devenir la
plaque tournante parce que fait la
différence essentielle mais si la
morosité du début des années 90 et il
annonce entre autres une le 25 août son
et 15 du départ de diouf tanza de
montréal qui devait décider de quitter
pour toronto et là on s'est dit bon il
faut 95 ans 95 ou dont il faut
effectivement et rétablir cette liaison
sur l'allemagne et air canada s'est
porté volontaire dans la mesure où on
est ramené à dornach
là il est trop tard pour remettre la
pâte dentifrice dentifrice est il trop
tard vu le même le démolir vous des noms
aussi le fait qu'on ait pas clairement
choisi mirabel avec un très rapide et
les voies rapides
il y avait pas urgence l époque parce
que encore une fois on avait perdu ses
passagers en correspondance
mais au fur et à mesure qu'on avait
besoin d'ajouter de la capacité qu'ont
développé des trains de banlieue par
exemple pour qu'on n'aurait plus
connectés mirabel et en faire une oeuvre
un aéroport qui est vraiment un avenir
avec une capacité quasi illimité mais
j'en crois la question qui se pose c'est
dans 15 20 ans est-ce qu'on va re des
friches et mirabel ou ailleurs on va
dire ça nous prend un plus grand
aéroport dans la grande région de
montréal où on
vie pour l'éternité à dorval et
forcément on est un peu dans une serre
l'on peut pas grandir je ferai pas la
même erreur que le passé de faire des
prévisions sur 20 ans mais à mon avis on
va fonctionner à l'intérieur des
contraintes de montréal trudeau pour
longtemps aéroports de montréal investit
tout près deux milliards de dollars qui
doivent rembourser 6 à long terme donc
on n'aurait même pas les moyens sont
vous y construire un nouvel aéroport
demain dans cinq ans dentiste dont on
sait vraiment enfermé dans cet aéroport
qui est enclavé et qui mérite toutes
sortes de problèmes à ses riverains et
d'accès etc et donc on ira plus en
quelques secondes
jamais de passager à mirabel on va
devoir enlever d'ailleurs les affiches
ça m'étonnerait en fait on continue tu
fais des correspondances à toronto parce
que c'est doc
air canada a établi sa plaque thomas et
le développement futur risque de se
faire davantage à toronto comme ouvrier
de quoi faire un cours que là dessus une
université de mauvaise gestion publique
de a à z avec tous les intervenants
c'est dans le monde un exemple de fiasco
assez extraordinaire effectivement on
est cité d'ailleurs en exemple d'un
monde déjà et jean karl rappelle à mes
étudiants sont assez découragés jacques
roy je vous remercie beaucoup d'ethnies
nous éclairer sur cette question je
pense que j'écrivais un livre là-dessus
ça s'en vient on devra en faire un
documentaire
je frissonne